Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, this is going
to be a breakdown of the viral trailer Game
of Thrones just posted.
It’s all about Arya and gets into some Braavos
stuff so careful for minor spoilers for some
specific Braavos Locations in that city.
It’s going to be one of the major new locations
the show does in addition to Dorne.
And Quick reminder that I’m running a weekly
giveaway for a copy of the Telltale video
game.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video.
So here we go.
Starting off it’s Arya having a waking dream.
It’s not specifically a warg dream because
we’re seeing visions of the past.
She remembers killing the Frey Guardsman after
the Red Wedding while the Hound just watched
with his jaw on the ground.
That was at the end of Season 3.
Then she remembers the time she killed Rorge
after she and The Hound came on the dying
man in the village.
Remember where the heart is.
That was late
season 4.
Then she sees herself giving the Bravoosi
coin to the ships captain in the season 4
finale.
The first time I saw her wrap her fingers
around the pommel here I thought it could
have been from back when she killed Biter
but she was wearing different clothes.
And her arm looks unusually clean here.
This looks like it’s from before she left
King’s Landing.
There haven’t been a lot of times she’s
tried to use a blade that’s clearly way
way too big and heavy for her.
Needle is the size of a large turkey knife.
So this is probably from a long time ago in
the past.
The last shot is the biggest, the Black and
White Doors of course being the entrance to
the House of Black and White in Braavos.
The temple of the Faceless Men, the order
to which Jaqen H’Gar belongs.
I’ve already done a couple bonus videos
about Braavos and the Faceless Men, so I’ll
add links in the description if you want to
learn all about those things.
That’s the only real new footage, but here’s
what’s going on.
HBO is using this to promote their viral website.
The Three Eyed Raven dot Com where you can
sign up for mobile alerts via text message
and twitter.
I would just recommend going with twitter
because text messages will cost you money.
I do a lot of my communicating between videos
on twitter too, there’s a link for that
in the description.
So you can also follow me for related Game
of Thrones updates.
HBO promotes each new season a little different
every year.
So the big question is what will they use
this new system for?
Mostly releasing new season 5 promos.
That will probably include everything from
footage, behind the scenes stuff or even just
images.
I’m not expecting the first full trailer
till the same time as last year.
And that was in February.
It was about 4 weeks before the start of season
5.
So don’t expect a huge long trailer till
then.
They will be posting official stuff, but it
will just be super short things like this
9 second teaser.
Because they went with the Three Eyed Raven
name I’m hoping they focus all the viral
content on Arya, Bran is supposed to not be
seen on screen at all so I don’t think any
of the content will invoke him.
Arya’s warg dreams have never been a big
thing on the show.
But all the stark children who’s direwolves
are still alive have the dreams.
No matter where they are in the world.
I think I talked about that in my direwolves
video.
But If they’re just doing Three-Eyed Raven
warg type teases they’d probably show new
footage of Jon up at the wall.
I don’t think they’ll do that, it’s
possible but here’s why.
Braavos is this new big exciting place we
haven’t seen a lot of, so if I were HBO
and I wanted to get people pumped up.
I’d just focus all my teasers there.
Especially if none of them are intended to
be full trailers.
You save all the other big characters for
that first trailer in february.
They kind of did that last year where they
had the wolf vision teasers for all the stark
children.
I didn’t really like those, I’m more a
fan of traditional trailers.
But I will give HBO a high five for trying
something creative in terms of marketing.
Just speaking as a fan I think this is interesting
but I feel like the Telltale Game will be
a more effective marketing tool.
Especially since it’s a legitimately good
game.
They’re sending me an advance copy in the
next week so I’ll let you know pretty soon
when I’ll start posting those videos.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I’ll post the first couple on this channel
and then I’ll move the gameplay stuff to
my game channel charlie streams.
Links for that in the description too.
Since a lot of the shows I do videos for are
going on break in the next couple of weeks
I might have some time for extra game of thrones
bonus videos so leave all your requests in
the comments.
Congratulations to the first winner of my
Telltale giveaway, Hannah M. You win a pre-order
on steam.
Please message me on my channel for details,
because I’ll need some contact info.
For people that want to buy the game it’s
on discount right now.
So you can get it on Steam for about 25 dollars.
Normally it will be 30 dollars.
but the price will probably go down.
I don’t think that includes a season pass
for all the future episodes.
There will be six total over the course of
next year.
Probably one new episode every two or three
months.
Reminder too: There are mobile links up here
if you’re watching on your phone or a tablet.
It’s the same as the links over here.
Click here to learn all about The Faceless
Men and Click here to Learn all about Braavos
thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!